patrick mahomes
recently speaking with reporters as it
relates to the toe remember we had the
turf toe injury the one injury that
doesn't sound nearly as bad as it is it
got worse during the super bowl he had
surgery three days after the loss to the
buccaneers here's mahomes talking about
the current status of his injured toe
no i don't i don't see any problems
moving forward obviously i want to
continue with the rehab continue to work
on those things to strengthen it and do
all that different type of stuff but i
feel like i had a good otas a good mini
cap i was able to move around scramble
around and do the things that i needed
to do
hey look here's the reality he can be
healthy now the question is can he stay
healthy he runs way too much he ran
around way too much in the super bowl
the loss to the raiders in the regular
season he ran around way too much when
you don't have that offensive line and
you just kind of oh yeah patrick will be
fine
sooner or later you're going to have
wear and tear
on the body that's carrying you around
as you run with your hair on fire trying
to find an open receiver and i think
that's what they need to be worried
about is this a cumulative thing that's
going to come back to haunt them if they
don't give him better protection and at
least they're trying to give him better
protection yeah i'm not going to blame
him for running too much in the super
bowl he's trying to make something
happen he's trying to win right right
but it was it's the full season of it it
culminates in that yes i think i i we uh
my podcast part of my take we have long
standing uh thought that turf toe needs
a rebrand because it does sound like the
lamest injury and it really is painful
and so you think oh he's got turf toe
who cares it's a real injury so we need
to rebrand turf toe we need it to sound
a lot more severe so that people take it
seriously
first time i ever heard of it was in the
70s frank o'hara's had it and it just
it's like he's got turf toe we'll go
wash his toe
it does not sound like a bad injury you
hear about all these hor that was the
first one where i was like that doesn't
really sound all that bad what's the
problem right exactly so rebrand rebrand
turf right we'll come up with something
let's come up with have you been you so
you're one of these guys who likes to
identify the problem but not come up
with a solution because what are you
talking about as to what we should call
it i'm gonna do it
john taffer i'm a disciple of john
taffer um i don't know
paralyzed toe that would be good
yes that may be a little too far the
other way but people will think of
people like oh he's got a paralyzed toe
this guy how's he walking it connotes
the severity of the injury all right uh
dwayne haskins in pittsburgh bargain
basement contract great opportunity for
the steelers mike tomlin said recently
he's working on crafting a personal
relationship with dwayne haskins why not
evaluate him to be the potential
successor to ben roethlisberger here's
haskins on what he's trying to prove
as he gets a a second chance at his nfl
career
just coming here to pittsburgh i just
wanted to prove to the coaching staff of
my teammates how much i love football
and just grateful opportunity to be here
and
showing that my mind's in the right
place and that i'm willing to work to be
able to show my talents and be able to
work and earn a spot here were you
surprised at your release by washington
i mean they just used the first round
pick on you it's your hometown team
in a little over a year later
they let you go
i wouldn't necessarily say i was
surprised i um it was part of the
business i wasn't necessarily the people
that
you know brought in by the coaching
staff and i'm understanding that this is
a business and um realizing that as the
season went on that um
it just things weren't going away that
we both wanted it to and um being able
to be here now on the spot
we can work hard and be able to figure
things out together and um you know just
great property in washington but it
wasn't completely surprising but i was
also definitely unfortunate to be able
to be released the way that i was
you know look some teams deal with their
mistakes by admitting them and moving on
like washington did other teams will
double down and just make it worse
bottom line is this so washington got
criticized so heavily for drafting
dwayne haskins with the 15th overall
pick after the fact at the time nobody
was saying anything because the guy was
going to be a first round pick he was
going to be selected in round one the
question was was it going to be in
washington or was it going to be
somewhere else so it's not like they did
some reach for some guy that was on
everyone's board as a fourth rounder and
and so the steelers have gotten a guy
who just two years ago was regarded as a
first-round talent for nothing but this
is great this is perfect and and now i
think this is one of the reasons why
teams will give guys second chances
they want the redemption to come
while he's on their team
they don't want the chris carter all he
does is catch touchdowns redemption when
he washes out of philly and he becomes a
hall of famer with minnesota teams want
that guy to wake up and still be part of
their organization
yeah
this is um dwayne haskins i don't i'm
not a believer but
if you were to pick where is the best
situation for him it's pittsburgh
because that is a franchise that has run
very well
that knows who they are that has a
process so uh it's great for him and
also he doesn't he obviously doesn't
have to start it's great for him the the
only downside would be if he can't make
it work here if something if they don't
see anything out of him in pittsburgh
that probably is it because that's you
can't really blame anyone if you go to
pittsburgh and and i'm not even talking
about starting i'm saying like just
being a good
model teammate who is you know doing
everything he needs to do to help the
team whether it be in practice or
however you want to slice it
pittsburgh is the spot so if he if he
fails here he's got no one to blame but
himself
and i agree with you it's going to be
xfl usfl something fl other than nfl if
it doesn't work for me in pittsburgh i p
pete just removed this from the list but
i think it's important that we address
this i know we're getting low on time
but i want to hear i want to hear
from brown's offensive coordinator alex
van pelt on otto beckham jr being back
with the browns because there is there
was the question last year when he got
injured because he put so much stress on
the quarterback because you got to get
in the ball you got to get him the ball
you got to get him the ball the the
argument was the offense is better
without him because baker mayfield
doesn't have to constantly look at otto
beckham jr well now the browns make it
to the divisional round they give the
chiefs everything they can handle otto
beckham jr is healthy here's alex van
pelt talking about the offense with obj
back on the field
anytime you have a great x you see a lot
of coverage roll to to that player
you know that kind of went away when
odell was injured
you know that that opens it up for for
other players to be successful um it's
not always great to be double teamed all
the time but sometimes that's going to
happen when you're great so um i would
expect teams to to i don't have to honor
odell and potentially at times put two
guys on
and i'm guessing that you'd think that
that concept of baker being better
without odell is
not true
i think baker was better
as the season went on whether it been no
dell or not had been on you know still
out there uh he started to understand
the offense more understand what we were
asking him got his footwork right um and
i think he just he he got better
regardless of who was on the field um as
i said earlier
you're always better with great players
um anytime you take a great player off
the field um you've got to find ways to
you know to generate more offense so
we'll be better with odell moved out
big hat this is so obvious to me the
browns will never put it this way
they'll never admit it but as i said
before we threw to the sound
having a guy on the field who is
constantly worried about getting the
ball getting the ball you got to get me
the ball that puts pressure on the
quarterback he holds on to that read
longer than he should he throws to the
guy maybe when he isn't open or maybe
when he is double covered because he's
got to get the ball he's got to get the
ball
it's if
otto beckham's healthy that's great but
he's got to lose that mindset that
we win if i get the ball we lose if i
don't that can't be the mindset going
forward totally agree it
it it's not just like a theory either it
showed in the numbers like it showed in
the play that the the browns were a more
efficient offense when he wasn't on the
field because of exactly what you said
so i i would assume
that last year was probably a little
humbling for odell beckham and i would
assume you'll have a little bit of a
difference here and if you're if the if
you're a part of a browns organization
that went to the playoffs for the first
time in forever that want a playoff game
against your bitter bitter rival in
their place
and then you come in and you get added i
think there's a little bit of a you know
introspection there where it's like okay
i don't want to rock the boat i want to
be able i want to be part of this this
looked like fun so let me be part of it
and not be the guy who comes in and
screws this whole thing up
i remember when they traded for him the
first thing i thought is is cleveland
big enough for both mayfield and obj and
i just feel like there's been that
tension there that gets put on mayfield
and mayfield's got to assert himself and
if otto beckham jr starts complaining
about it this year
mayfield's got to tell him basically sit
down and shut up i'm the one who decides
where the football go
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports